This is one of those videos where
I don't really know what's going to happen.
The production team just told me to report
to the workshop of Florian Gadsby.
I make videos for YouTube, and I make pots.
So I make bowls, mugs, teapots.
Anything you can think of,
functional, I make it.
I suspect I know the answer to this,
but what am I gonna be doing?
We're going to try and get you to
make a mug from beginning to end.
Alright. Something—
I mean, it's not gonna look
this professional, I guess, but...
That's our target. So we're gonna be—
That's actually—?
This was not—
This was not a deliberate prop.
This is just—
I just left my mug there. Okay.
So yeah. We'll be throwing it,
we'll be trimming it,
and then we'll be putting
the handle on at the end.
Alright.
Attempting to, at least.
Wish me luck.
I'm guessing we start with
the big lump of clay.
A smaller lump, but yes.
This is the clay we're gonna be using.
Before we begin the process,
we need to wedge it.
Wedging the clay essentially removes
all the pockets of air that are inside,
and it makes sure that the lump of clay
is basically the same texture throughout.
So there's no hard lumps
or giant pockets of air,
'cause they just
hinder your progress later, so...
This is sort of like a dance.
There's a dance element to it.
It's repeating the same
couple of maneuvers,
time and time again, over and over.
First thing we're gonna do is
take our block of clay,
and we're gonna whack it into
sort of a rectangular block.
Okay. That is...
So...
It's stickier than I expected.
Yeah, it is.
It's... I guess one of the things
with clay is trying to...
It's messy, right?
So you have to work with it in a way
where you minimise that,
otherwise life gets horrible, but...
This is what I do absentmindedly
if I've got a little bit of Blu Tack,
or something like that.
You're gonna be a master.
You might be an expert.
It's just a very big bit of Blu Tack
that sticks way more than I expect it to.
So once we've got the block...
now the routine really starts, so...
We're gonna take the lump of clay
and hold it from underneath.
And we're gonna
hit it down on the table.
So now you see, you've got a cavity underneath.
Oh yeah, there's room here. Cool, yeah.
So then you take your wire...
Yeah.
Nice and taut,
you slide it halfway through.
This is called cut wedging,
and it'll become obvious,
and you cut halfway through it,
so it splits in two lumps.
Yep, okay.
So as you can see in yours,
there's a giant...
There's a big hole.
There's a big air pocket,
which is not what we want.
So, you take this lump...
Right. Yep.
and if you draw an X, and an X
on the top portions...
X, X.
we take the one lump,
put the Xs
so they're facing each other...
and then we slam this down
onto the one below.
There you go.
And the hole is gone...?
The hole is sort of gone.
The hole is— No, it's still—
It'll eventually—
Still just there.
What we've done is
we've made two layers, right?
Yep.
If you do this 20 times,
there's more than ten million layers.
It's like laminating dough.
...Oh!
So by the time, hopefully...
there are ten million layers,
there should be no pockets of air,
and it should be entirely smooth
and even in texture.
So now we're back
to this starting process.
So...
Yeah.
Drop it down, so there's a space underneath.
Get your wire.
Take your wire.
Pull up halfway.
Perfect.
And... slam it down...
X, X.
And there's another big gap.
It'll be gone.
Right, what we can do at this point,
'cause yours is quite tall,
you can pick up the whole thing again,
and just whack it upside-down
again like that.
And it should flatten it.
Yes, it does!
So then we have our block shape.
♪ (light acoustic music)
It's a good arm workout.
You know what,
that was a bad job.
There we go.
There you go.
It's about how hard you—
Yeah.
Good blend.
There we go!
Down.
I don't know why I'm
worried about breaking it.
(laughs)
It's how we were trained
when I was in Japan.
This is what we did for hours,
in the mornings and the afternoons.
(chuckles)
Okay.
But, let's have a look.
So let's cut through.
I think we might
more or less be there.
Let's have a look.
(music ends)
I mean, that looks pretty good to me.
Just to say, I mean, these are just
the wire marks, obviously.
And you can see— You're right.
You can see the whole—
There's a grain through the thing,
going that way.
Yeah, that's also the lamination
from the cut wedging.
So I think we're ready to go to the next bit.
Alright!
We're gonna start with...
about... 450 grams per lump.
So next, what we do...
is we just take each lump...
Yep.
and we're gonna...
Right.
Wait, what's—
You made that look very easy.
and then I realised I'm not
actually sure what you're doing there.
So basically, I'm using...
Cup hand.
Cupping the hands to make a ball.
Hands stay more or less in the same
cup shapes, so I don't actually—
See how you're opening and closing
your hand as you do it?
Keep that hand in that cup shape.
Okay.
Your left hand is gonna be
throwing it in, taking it out.
Oh, okay.
And every time you take it out,
you rotate it slightly,
So you're hitting into a different...
Okay.
Oh, that's really...
It's quite tricky,
'cause you want to do that.
It is. I want to throw it into both hands,
like that, like I'm juggling.
Yes.
And that's not...
Essentially though,
all we want is a round ball.
Okay.
Alright. Well...
they're a bit cracked,
and a bit...
less spherical than yours, but...
They're fine. They're fine.
They'll do.
Alright.
So, we can now take our balls
over to the wheels.
Alright.
And we can start the process.
Ne-aah...
Got em?
You say we can— You say that.
This way.
(stammers and chuckles)
So we just stick em
on this bucket for now.
Oh god!
Oh!
There we go.
Ball down, there we go.
Okay, yeah, fine, there.
Okay. Sure.
Perfect. Okay.
So... these are the wheels.
This is where I spend—
This is—
Most people spend their day
at a desk maybe.
This is where I am.
Okay.
They work sort of like a car,
not that I drive, really.
Oh, there's an accelerator pedal.
Yep, and if I push that...
It does exactly what you might imagine.
So, you've never thrown on the wheel before.
No, this is completely new.
And we're just gonna go right in.
Okay, so...
We take a ball of clay.
Alright.
And I aim...
First thing we have to do is get it
stuck to this portion of the wheel
as hard as we can.
Right in the middle. Okay.
Maybe that's why it's called throwing,
'cause you throw the ball into the middle.
It's contested.
And you gotta hit that target just there.
You want it to be as centre as possible,
and you also—
If you place it like this,
it's just gonna come off.
Oh, so—
So you want—
So earlier, my clay was getting
stuck to the table, and that was a bad thing.
Now I need to really...
Now we want it to be stuck here.
When you throw it down,
you want to throw it with vigour.
Get it.
...Not quite central there.
Excellent. It doesn't matter.
What you can do is
you can tap it, from one side.
Oh, I can. Alright.
And you can spin the wheel as well,
just a touch, to see sort of how it's going.
I mean it's not... There we go.
That's— I'm okay with that.
It doesn't need to be perfect.
So then—
Good! (chuckles)
At this stage, it's fine.
So then, what we want...
Water is vital.
To reduce friction.
Exactly, so water—
'Cause otherwise,
it's just gonna tear in my hands.
It will just stick to your hands,
and then the whole thing will come off.
Before we do anything,
we have to get the clay centred.
And this is not centered enough.
Right.
So what we do is
you take your left elbow,
and you stick it into your torso.
Yeah.
This is gonna be like
your anchoring arm, essentially.
Oh right, yep.
What this is gonna do—
If you lean your upper body weight
onto that arm...
It's very stable, right?
So... (claps hands)
Yes it is.
What we want is stability here.
Alright.
So, before we get started,
let's just use some water.
If you'll cup your hand.
Yeah.
Give the wheel a good spin.
Yeah, so you're pushing
down and in from the side.
But you see how your wrist
is wobbling a little bit?
Yeah. Uh!
If you focus on keeping that wrist
as steady as possible,
so that means pushing it
really quite hard.
Generally, at the beginning,
people don't use enough pressure.
Yeah, I'm letting the clay move me there.
Yes. So you want to—
So that just needs to be jabbed into my torso.
And if you feel any friction,
more water.
So if you feel that here it's
getting quite sandy, for instance,
just get some more water, put it on.
Alright.
That feels pretty good.
You see how much difference
the water makes.
It makes it flow.
Right, yeah.
But once we got a—
Basically what we want is a...
a little disc shape, a puck,
that isn't wobbling.
We don't want walls
that look like that.
We want something
that's steady and...
I guess just spinning
as true as possible on the wheel.
So that is good.
I didn't appreciate, like...
Ceramics were not a thing
that I ever really...
If you go around the museum,
and there's a ceramics exhibit,
I would've probably just
walked straight past it.
And I guess I'd never really appreciated
quite how much goes into this.
I mean, it's so fascinating,
if you think about it,
'cause you're taking the material,
which is essentially worthless,
you know, clay from riverbeds and things.
And it's also fascinating,
depending where you are in the world,
people are using clays,
but they're all different.
They have different makeups,
and you end up with different products entirely.
So pots made in one region
will look different from any other place.
I think I've centered that.
That's good.
The next thing
we have to make, obviously—
at the moment, this is not
anywhere near a mug shape.
Yep.
So we've got to create
the well in the middle,
which then we open up
into the base of the pot.
Alright, yep.
So...
The way I do it is
wet hands again...
Wet hands.
And we're gonna use our thumbs...
Yep.
and they're gonna push
just gently into the middle.
Okay.
And we're just pushing down,
quite firmly,
and your hands on the outside
are tucked around it as best you can.
Yeah, I— Yeah. Okay!
There's a very different look
between these two.
They're okay.
One of these is the work of
a decade of experience.
(laughs) someone who has...
Everyone's started there.
Okay.
You can only get better.
(laughs)
Can't get worse(!)
No.
Well, it will get worse.
Okay, good.
Just like our wedging,
we follow a sequence, right?
With a pot, we've centered it,
we've made the hollow in the middle,
we've opened it to form the base,
and now we have to pull the walls up,
so creating height.
I'm kinda glad that the walls here
are thicker than yours then.
Yes. You've got more clay.
I've got more clay to work with, alright.
This is probably—
I probably shouldn't say this.
This is the hardest part by far.
(chuckles) Okay.
Make a fist with your right hand.
Extend your knuckle like that.
Yep.
And then you rotate it like that.
Okay.
This is gonna be our lifting knuckle.
Alright.
That's how potters push the clay up.
Oh right, okay!
So it goes in there, and you pull up like that.
It tucks in the corner.
I just touched it while it wasn't rotating,
That's fine, it's fine.
and that's why
you don't do that, okay.
And you can just gently
collar it in from all sides,
kind of applying even pressure.
Yeah.
I would maybe be angling
slightly inward a bit.
Okay.
And once they're there,
let's have a look.
Okay, so that's better.
Alright. Yeah, okay.
It's now an easier shape to work,
because if you keep pulling the walls up,
they'll keep splaying
out and out and out,
and then it's very obviously
not a mug.
I could feel that moving underneath me.
Okay, that's good, but you see,
you've got some height there.
You've got about 1.5 cm taller,
so that's fine. Very good.
Okay, so again,
if you feel any friction...
Yep.
Add water.
Oh, that's nearly
got away from me. Aah.
You've got it. For your
first attempt at pulling the walls,
Pulling the walls is typically the part—
Okay, so that's fine.
Oh, we've got a little bit of a...
We're uneven there, aren't we?
We're gonna go through the finishing procedures.
Let me just get— I'll get mine to a rough,
more of your kind of shape.
Thanks(!) (giggles)
Imitate the novice here.
God, the...
That's just a...
Okay, so...
Just watching the movement
of the clay up there, it's beautiful.
It's hypnotic.
Yeah!
I think that's why people like it,
in a way, because it's—
Also, you can't do anything else
when you're throwing a pot.
You can't look at your phone,
you can't be distracted.
(laughs)
You're there completely
in the moment.
Okay.
So you've got a serrated,
like a twisted wire, between two bits.
Then we're just gonna drag it,
keeping it as taut as possible, underneath.
There you go.
And then basically,
you wanna just lift.
Yeah, okay. I've got it, I've got it.
You've got it?
And just move it over to the back,
and then just let go.
That happened significantly faster
than I thought it was going to.
So there we go.
Okay!
I mean, there's...
(laughs)
It's not bad!
Honestly for your first try...
It's more of a soup bowl,
but I'll take that.
You can trim it to be thinner,
add a nice little handle.
But I would say it's worth
probably doing...
maybe having two or three.
Okay.
So what do you think, should we keep throwing?
Montage.
♪ (jazzy acoustic music)
[muttering]
Bit more water. Down in the middle.
That looks great.
Really well centered.
Lift gently off
when you get to the top.
Oh.
Agh.
(groans loudly)
(music stops)
It's gonna happen.
Chuck it in there. Goodbye.
♪ (polka-like acoustic music)
Whoa! No I can't.
Let's go again.
Okay.
There we go.
There you go.
Woo.
(music ends)
Okay, yeah.
Good! Honestly, for your first try...
(chuckles) I'll take—
For doing something that's completely—
you've never done before,
and using your arms,
it's good.
Right, so onto the next step.
Okay!
We make a sphere,
and I'm gonna roll out one end.
Okay.
Like that.
So it's sort of like a...
what do you call it, a teardrop?
Or...
Yeah, okay. A pear.
A pear. Excellent.
So that's the shape we're starting off with.
Okay.
We hold it up with one hand.
Yeah.
And I want it at kind of eye level.
Okay.
Wet hand.
Really wet hand.
And you can even dunk the end of it.
I really appreciate that's warm water.
Thank you, that's really nice.
What I'm gonna do is
I'm basically pulling it...
Okay.
...down.
How on earth...?
Right...?
...Okay.
So I'm basically—
That's like stretching taffy.
It's exactly that.
Yeah, exactly like that.
Okay.
I reach the top,
Yeah.
I'm squeezing,
and I'm pulling down while I'm
maintaining that same pressure...
Okay.
throughout until I get to the bottom.
(sighs)
Then what I do is I...
switch it around,
and I can pull from the other side.
That way, I'm pulling—
That's our template.
Yeah.
This, between our hands.
Oh, this isn't going well.
This is not going well.
I would say go faster.
Okay.
Go faster.
Wetter hand.
Any kind of bits that come off,
just chuck 'em; we'll make a pile.
I think you're squeezing a bit too hard...
Yeah.
and moving a bit too slowly.
Okay, so it's...
Less pressure.
Yeah.
Like that, that was better.
Much better.
And template you said is about
what the width of what a handle should be.
Sort of, I mean...
...Yeah. (laughs)
So stick it there.
And using your thumb,
like it'll, you know...
snip off one portion
like that.
When I'm doing production throwing...
How accurate are those?!
They're identical,
every single one of them!
Yeah, yeah.
But it's making 10,000 of these that's...
But again, the joy of this process is
you don't need to be completely accurate.
They are...
As long as you've got a few more,
you might rip one off.
There is an obvious difference there!
Yeah, it's night and day(!)
No. But the joy is, it's fine.
It doesn't matter.
How do we attach these to the mugs
without them falling off?
We're gonna take our mug.
I will go with this little fellow.
Yeah.
And we're gonna use one of these,
which is just a serrated kidney.
Okay.
Again, this where your own idea
comes into it, your own aesthetic.
So depending on where
you want the handle to spring from...
Okay.
...depends on where we're gonna use this.
Take the kidney;
we're just gonna scratch in.
Doesn't need to be too deep.
It's just to roughen up the surface basically.
Okay.
(metal tool clangs)
Then what we do is
take the paintbrush, with the slip,
so this is just watered-down clay.
Yep.
And that's just dabbed on.
Not too much. Just enough.
This is basically glue.
This whole process, it's like—
Right, and the serrated edge
increases the surface area.
Exactly. When you find broken pots
in the ground, wherever,
often the pots you find left are
the handle join, this portion.
It's actually stronger than the clay walls.
Oh yeah. Right, okay.
If done correctly.
If done— (chuckles)
So put your mug down.
Oh right, yep.
We take our handle blanks.
Yep.
Then we take our other hand,
one or two fingers.
I use probably just one,
and we're just going to pat it down.
So now we're left with the handle
with a flare on one end.
Take this, and we're gonna hold it
sort of from the end.
And again, when we're attaching it,
we don't wanna ruin the integrity of this length.
So don't squeeze too much
in the middle, or on one end.
We put one hand inside,
opposite the area,
and that's just to brace it.
Yeah.
And then you push the handle blank
onto the scored area.
Okay.
Just like that.
Yeah. Just like that.
Then we can pick the mug up.
Okay. Ah, that's gonna—
Alright.
It'll stay on. I mean...
Okay. Yeah, okay.
This is the test. Go on.
Ah yeah, okay!
It's on.
So now comes the tricky bit.
(chuckles) Now comes the tricky bit.
Everything's easy.
Because now, it's make-or-break.
'Cause you can ruin your pot
in this stage as well.
Okay. Okay.
So, it's very much like before.
Mhm.
We're pulling in the same way
over the water.
You just need to be more delicate.
Oh... okay.
With my wet hand, I'm grasping,
again, right near the top,
where my hands meet the mug.
Yeah.
And I'm just gently—
I'm barely— I'm barely squeezing.
It's just a tiny amount of pressure.
Okay, yep.
Then we're gonna take
the bottom of the handle.
Yep.
And then we're going to
bring the mug down,
and the handle down together.
There you go, and try if you can,
to get some of the excess,
so it goes in...
There you go. Yeah.
That.
And then we can squidge that excess
against the mug like that.
Yeah.
Rub it in from side to side.
And then we can pinch off
the excess that was there.
Hey!
(laughs)
There you go.
It looks like a handle.
It does technically look like a handle, yes.
And it matches the mug.
In many...
(laughs)  In so many ways!
So many ways.
Alright.
Nice. So, onto the next?
Two more.
♪ (bright acoustic music)
It's got that ridge.
...opening.
Yeah, okay.
Just that. Alright.
If you did that for
a thousand more hours...
(music ends)
(laughs) Yes!
you'll be fine.
So, what happens now?
Now what I'll do with these pots
is I'll dry them out slowly
until they're completely bone-dry,
like the mugs you can see there.
Yep.
Once they're at that stage,
they'll go in the electric kiln,
and they're fired to
1000 degrees Celsius overnight.
Then what I do is I'll glaze them,
so they're dipped into buckets of glaze.
Then they're put in the gas kiln,
and fired for about nine hours
up to 1,300 degrees, more or less.
(exhales) Alright.
And then that takes a couple days
to cool down, and then that's it.
So hopefully we'll see yours
in a week or so.
Yeah.
I'll see you then.
Thank you. See ya.
♪ (jazzy acoustic music)
(gas vents)
(scrapes roughly)
The packaging is lovely.
That's the pale green glaze.
So it's the middle size you made.
Not the one with the big ridge, but...
That's lovely! I— I—
That's actually a working mug!
That's functioning.
And yeah, the glaze makes it whole
and it unifies the surface.
The thing is,
the glaze is in your style,
so this looks like someone doing
a really bad knockoff imitation!
It looks like what you get if you order
a Florian Gadsby mug off Wish.com.
Well, that's actually a very precious
collaborative effort, so...
That's lovely. And the...
One of a kind.
The initials made it through as well.
It did. It's always...
It is very strange seeing
other people's pots with my glazes.
But, um...
Yeah, it...
It almost feels like
I'm ripping you off somehow.
It's a very strange sight
to see something
that looks like it should be
on your wall, and yet is...
charitably...
...has a curious shape.
Exactly.
But now you can use something
that you've made yourself
for tea and coffee,
or whatever you like.
Oh, so that's the dark glaze.
That's the dark green one.
Okay, so this is...
this is a bit too heavy.
(both chuckle)
and it's bulging in some...
strange places.
Yeah, I mean heavy, and then once it's
filled up with tea or coffee, it'll be even more so.
But...
usable.
Technically usable.
A Christmas gift to a family member maybe.
Oh yeah, no,
that's absolutely happening.
(both laugh)
I think the last one's my favourite.
It has the most unusual shape,
(laughs)
but it works for it, I think.
And the glaze is—
Oh, this is very short and squat, isn't it?
It is short and squat,
but it's...
There you go.
(laughs)
It's unusual.
That's, um...
But it makes a good groove for your thumb.
When you hold it, your thumb...
The indentation makes,
there's extra room for your digit.
I don't think you want that extra room!
No?
I'll be honest, it's better than
I thought I was gonna manage.
It's— It's not great,
but I'm happy enough with that.
Thank you so much.
You're very welcome.
Where can people find you?
I'm "Florian Gadsby" on most platforms.
YouTube, Instagram, TikTok.
We'll put a link up.
I think that's all.
♪ (jazzy acoustic music)
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]